thank you
hey everybody and welcome to a
determined wild ride with Stevo we've
got Trevor Wallace a self-made success
he builds himself up from nothing with
help from nobody and just kept at it
making stuff making stuff like the
gorgeous Paul Briskey says he made stuff
until he made it and what a great
conversation we have we both also reveal
some deep-seated resentments right we uh
we go ahead and air out our grievances
for the whole world to listen to I think
you're really going to find it juicy and
hilarious so let's get into it
ladies and gentlemen Trevor Wallace
what's up thanks for having me this is
awesome about this makes me want to take
my shirt off you know maybe it's the fur
on the wall okay take your shirt off
Epic Man my Burt Chrysler in it right
now dude I don't know I don't have the
body for that I have the body for a
[__] podcasting you know you have the
best body in here thank you yeah well
you guys have tattoos and that adds so
many points yeah that's true yeah I used
to have my ears gauged but that's about
it yeah dude yeah it was pretty pretty
sick in high school I can put my pinky
through my ear
you saw it it grows back a little bit
this was so as a hole in it but it
tightens up a little yeah my mom said
that like when she's working for plastic
surgeon that is one of the major
surgeries people were coming in to do
was like get their gauges filled where
did she work like Inland Empire that's a
very specific exactly I mean that was
the only thing that she did but yeah
yeah yeah
I thought chicks would want it and then
it was only guys being like dude do your
gauges smell too and I was like this is
terrible this is not why I got this just
so doozy come up what did you put in
there you putting carrots in there
it's very interesting yeah he added so
uh see you've been blowing up man have I
I think I think so man I thank God
things appear to be going very well for
you yeah things are going good man which
is awesome I'm uh just excited and just
really I'm just trying a bunch of [__]
because I don't even know what the
hell's going on the internet changes so
much every day I'm like what do people
want right what uh was
like what started it off like you you
weren't like part of a show or like
there wasn't any one thing that
catapulted you onto the singing right
you just was it fine I was on Vine but I
don't have any like followers on there
like I was making [__] but just for like
12 people you know I had like one thing
do like a couple thousand views and
somebody recognized me on my way to
class in college like you're online
right I played it so cool I was like
[__] yeah I am but I think I've just
been steady making videos since like
2016 ish you know it's divine [__] like
2013-14 that died out and then I was
just making a bunch of videos on like
Facebook and YouTube yeah I was the guy
who was like I was a weird you know
garyvee is always preaching some crazy
[__] I was that guy I was like
Facebook's gonna be big because of
shareability you know it's uh nothing
else had that like besides Twitter of
that like retweet that share moment
right yeah when stuff pops up on
Facebook or when it used to pop up on
Facebook it's just so easy to share and
people on Facebook got opinions for days
so they're like he needs to hear about
this you know an engagement you know
people just commenting yeah it's pretty
rad though to like just come out of
nowhere like you didn't have anybody
like on your
yeah it wasn't like a big Mentor you
were just chipping away at it from the
ground level and just chipping away and
chipping away and persistent and making
funny stuff yeah now you're yeah I think
I just held myself to a standard I was
like I'm just gonna post a video once a
week I'd film like Saturday Sunday and
then edit it and then they'd go up
Monday when I was still working my day
job and I was like
you know I just one video Hit and then
like for me I was like all right let's
just keep this fire going that's the
momentum because I'm fine I had one
video do like decent and then I just
stopped I got nervous I was like I don't
know what the [__] you make next and
then it just died out so for me I always
think about videos like it's a fire and
you just keep throwing logs and each log
yeah is a you know and you're just
trying to keep growing keep it building
keep it yeah notice like that comedians
that put their sets on Facebook tend to
sell out their shows too really well
Facebook it's just an audience you know
I mean they're not the most not your
sets you mean like just Clips I'm sorry
Clips Josh Wolf does that a lot yeah and
he's he's a second because everything's
so impacted on all the other like big
apps like Instagram Tick Tock you go to
Facebook there's like not that much
competition you know it's like you and
like a southern mom being like top five
ways to breastfeed you know and then you
throw up a stand-up clip in there and
like oh yeah titties and stand up
yeah it's it's fascinating so you got
your you're you're still doing the stiff
socks yeah yeah dude yeah that was
awesome I uh I still had the hot sauce
from when you came on dude that's
phenomenal I brought you a bunch of
gifts man I got you I got uh yeah that
sounds great in honor of your stiff
socks podcast
yeah dude socks dude I didn't know you
had butt wives that's awesome yeah
Stevo's butt wipes for your butthole
well I mean it makes sense uh with the
sauce it's a one-two combo
Amazon you know when you're buying
something it's like did you also want to
buy yeah those are on Amazon yeah you
bought a flashlight did you also want to
buy therapy sessions
this is awesome I literally have the
ones that are like you know I don't want
to give any free promo bleep it out dude
wipes but like this is so much more it's
like if I saw this in somebody's
bathroom I'd be like this guy shits yeah
it's fun he knows how to [__] these are
great socks dude so what haven't you put
your face on
um there's not this mug shot
oh [__] yeah there you go that's there
oh [__] A mugshot mug God damn dude this
is next level this is beautiful dude
thank you yeah dude so uh okay so so you
get the stiff socks podcast going yeah
you uh you're prolific making sketch
comedy on social media you're doing
stand up yep and so those are like the
three lanes yeah okay yeah that's kind
of like what the Venn diagram is I'd say
it's uh and I started stand up first so
that's always kind of like been like the
passion I have you ever done like
Ventura Harbor comedy club sure yeah
that's where that's like my hometown
Club so I think it closed down during
the pandemic but
um that's where I started out uh when I
was 17. so you grew up in Camarillo yeah
close by yeah yeah yeah you know it or
you just hit the Wikipedia I know it and
I hit the wick oh yeah no I know it and
I saw before they were famous oh really
yeah yeah dude yeah Camarillo we have
this tendency to do it's like crash it's
like cramming for a test of course
so like what I do uh I'll type in the
name of the guest and documentary oh you
know like I want to see like somebody
put together a documentary I did that
for you yeah and all I got was was uh
like just your content which is probably
a really good that's good for you
because it's feeding me like all of your
like [__] boy videos yeah yeah like uh
your Zoomies yeah the Zoomies one was
based on the Zoomies in camarillos like
I actually uh like that character was
the first thing that really kind of hit
in like 2017 I was making fun of those
yeah no better job at Costco yeah I did
so long
dude I've had the most random beta jobs
in the world selling blinds and frozen
yogurt and Jamba Juice Jamba Juice and
uh you started at a comedy club in San
Jose uh San Jose College San Jose Improv
I was doing some sleep spots there was
the part of what they said was uh that
at your college you started a space for
open night so there was a stand-up
comedy club like like club like
Gathering of a club uh and I like I
remember I submitted an email it's like
this is my resume I performed here
they're like dude we don't we've never
even done stand-ups come by
so it's fun we just meet up in like a
lecture hall on like Tuesdays and like
run jokes past each other that's cool
it's pretty neat dude you know I I
started noticing you when when we were
the last time we were in Oklahoma City
doing shows yeah you were coming the
week after us oh really and it was like
right at the start of the pandemic Brick
House yeah that was uh the last weekend
I did before the pandemic yeah that was
the second of last week we went out
there and then the pandemic hit yeah and
then I saw you on I'm like man this
guy's [__] blowing up everywhere wait
we went out to Oklahoma and that was the
first show after the World opened up a
little bit in 21. but whatever
um what but I do remember the last week
and I remember it was like on stage it
had like a one gallon thing of hand
sanitizer this was like right before the
world shut down a week before and the
manager was like you know if you do a
meet and greet and you want to use that
I was like yeah okay then I'm on the
flight and everyone's coughing around me
I was like oh this is real then a week
later I couldn't leave the [__] house
yeah so I started it is what I'm trying
to say yeah I didn't didn't put it on
the meeting patient zero yeah exactly
exactly
so uh the the podcast is crushing yeah
it's doing well man
um it's a lot of fun it's a mixture of
stuff we've had a few porn stars on now
everybody's just like is it a porn
podcast no I'm just yeah how did porn
stars perform for you on there great I
mean the internet is horny as they say
so yeah uh you know it's as much as you
know if you and I just had a podcast
where boys and boys go back and forth
you know it's fun people like it and
then for whatever reason you have uh the
gorgeous miss Angela White on the
internet I need to know what she eats
for breakfast every day you know it's
yeah we should totally get a porn star
on the podcast you guys never done it
but that's the thing is that Steve's
like nobody wants to hear about a porn
star no no no they might have PTSD but
this is the one I hear about it so yeah
they might be like I think I signed in
here somewhere no it's um we've had
women perform
particularly poorly on the podcast yeah
but they're not porn stars
let me put it to you this way I was
looking up like uh back in the day top
searched websites and Google's number
one right
Corn's number two is it really like wow
billions of hits a day you're either
trying to figure out how to install a
sink or be like who can I [__] jerk
off to tonight yeah and so just based
off of people Googling like porn is the
most looked up website of all time neck
and neck with Google and I'm on Google
every day and you're also on something
else every day yeah so I I stopped
watching pornography a long time ago oh
nice sorry I didn't mean to bring up the
p word I'm not good I'm not I'm not I'm
not crying about it yeah Scott and I
both have had issues with that how are
you doing with that pretty horribly oh
you're actually treating yourself to
yeah yeah once in a while so I have a
self-soothing because I'm single yeah
and it's like you know I have a question
I mean was there a moment with porn
where you like kind of picked your head
up and you're like I'm [__] jerking
off to the Family Guy ad it's like was
there a defining moment where you're
like oh this is gone too deep I noticed
that
um in relationships if I was acting out
with porn that like you know I just
wasn't getting it done yeah it's with my
lady you know like it's it's like taking
your energy
it's taking your energy away from the
relationship and putting it into a sock
yeah yeah I was just wondering because
you know with a lot of uh addiction
stuff it's like you kind of have a
moment where you wake up and you go last
night was too much or you have a a
moment where you're like I gotta get my
[__] together I always wondered was it a
video but it sounds like yours was just
kind of an experience well I mean for me
man oh yeah they think we might want to
go there the whole like sex addiction
thing yeah
um man I uh
there there was this this
chick that I met after uh one of my
shows a long time ago this was uh
beginning of 2013.
you know what else happened a long time
ago I stopped paying stupid amounts of
money for five blade razors because I
discovered Harry's and man I've been
using them for
four years three years now I've not
shaved my face with another razor except
my hairs because I love it it's
everything I need top quality five blade
German engineered razors and I mean it's
this weighted ergonomic handle it's
Sleek it's classy it's awesome nothing
that you don't need just what you do
need and if you go to harrys.com
Stevo you get this whole starter kit
with foaming shave gel the weighted
ergonomic handle the five blade razor
the travel cover to protect the razor
it's everything you need and it's a 13
value but there gonna give it to you for
just three dollars if you go to
harrys.com
Stevo one more time that's the whole
starter kit 13 value you get it for just
three bucks if you head on over to
harrys.com
Stevo thank you Harry's now let's get
back to it and she was with a dude
and I'm like oh yeah she was like stoked
to meet me and I'm like oh like let me
get your numbers right in front of her
dude oh wow she gives me the gifts gives
me your number and then and then like I
hit her up after and she's like oh you
know I'm with this dude and I was like
okay if no fair enough fair enough but
then like like a week or two later she's
like I broke up with the dude I'm like
right on cool so I fly her out yeah to
uh to LA and and you know we're doing
our thing
I remember too I used to be pretty good
about like uh protection stuff in this
case like do we just we weren't yeah
yeah we're just we're just rocking it
rawing it raw dogging it up and uh and
so we've been we've been at that for a
couple days and then I'd take her up on
this hike to go get a photo with the
Hollywood Sign there you go she says you
know it's so weird you know that guy I
was with his last relationship before me
was with a dude
and I'm like oh oh I see where you're
going now I'm thinking like this is high
risk for for your boy yeah high risk for
like for HIV you know and I'm like
spinning I'm spinning I remember like we
got back to my apartment and and I'm
like I gotta walk the dogs and while I'm
walking the dogs around the block I'm
just Googling statistics on oh yeah well
also Hollywood has so many of those
Billboards it's like one in three HIV
you have two dogs you're like it's
[__] not me
I'm uh yes I'm freaking out but then I
get back to the pad and I'm like well
you know like
I'm already in it this far got it but it
was true
and so here here um you know and then
I'm just doing it again and while I'm
doing it again I'm thinking like man
what is my deal yeah you know that was
like
how long did you get into something
after that like a program
um
I that was when I first reached out to
someone saying ahead you know I mean
and I need to get it get a handle on
this and and and
trying to get a handle on it
that I just couldn't yeah like I started
seeing a sex therapist and they said uh
you know like it's gonna be important
for you to to to be like celibate for
like a period you know let's try
I think he said like let's try two weeks
we're just no we're not gonna do
anything you know like no no no nothing
no nothing I think it's weird how
celibacy doesn't really get uh
celebrated you know like if if your
friends like I'm six months off alcohol
you're like that's [__] great but
like I feel like one of your friends
like I haven't had sex in six months
you're like [__] [__] you know like
you feel like right it's like I'm not
yeah I remember telling that like I was
trying it and I didn't just couldn't I
couldn't I couldn't you know yeah and
and it was this comedy of errors and at
the time I was doing stand-up and like I
was just getting I was just like getting
material out of like how how impossible
it was for me to to yeah and and it
turned out that like that whole first
hour my whole first special was like you
know very focused on on the issues with
sex
um but I remember like I got to a point
where I really was you know it's
committed to I ended up going to this
this outpatient sex addict rehab and uh
and and coming out of there that's how I
met Scott I was like yo I just got out
of sex addict rehab you guys are the
same place
um no I didn't go but it's kind of the
same rooms okay yeah so so I'm like I
just got out of sex addict rehab and I
got to go back on tour I have no chance
whatsoever that's the ultimate final
test I need a c blocker yeah yeah your
therapist is like now you're gonna do a
50 City tour in all the U.S near college
towns right so so I was like if I was
like maybe you know if you come on the
road like uh you can sell merch at my
shows for me and like you can get some
money like uh coming in from
professional paid [__] block that's
great yeah and and that was exactly how
it started and then so that was how
Scott started with my merch operation
but that's beautiful so I was I was
celibate for over a year and I remember
telling Knox I was like dude I didn't
even blow a load [__] it's been like six
months Knoxville's like
dude he's really concerned he says to me
um he says dude that's like uh that's
how you're gonna get uh testicular
cancer if you let it back up damn and I
remember Santa Knoxville like dude I'm
pretty sure that if uh
if if jacking off was the cure for
testicular cancer nobody would have it
could you imagine that the doctor's like
I got good news and bad news and he just
slides Brazzers across the table I can
save you yeah
that's wild I mean that's that's like a
rumor that like a 17 year old would
start like if you don't jack off dude
you're gonna lose a ball
it was a yellow five would you ever hear
that yellow yeah Mountain Dew make your
balls smaller oh I did hear that yeah
and there was a period where I would
have a bag of Skittles and I would put
the yellows to the side I'd be like [__]
it not today okay
I need these all right or like uh if you
have acnes because you have too much
sperm built up inside you I've never
heard that I've never heard that really
it's just trying to get out of your box
that's why it has the white heads on it
I didn't even tell you that if anything
it would be the other way around can you
imagine if that was like oh you're like
you're getting acne because you have a
like two depleted you know yeah too much
that would be wild if somebody had an
acne you just put your face mask back on
rocking a hard spot yeah that's how
Kellogg started was to like lower the
sex drive the cereal the cereal I think
it was meant to lower the the sex drive
Kellogg cereal well I mean saying the
word Kellogg is probably the least horny
thing you can do besides Raisin Bran so
yeah like back in the day that's maybe I
I don't maybe it was a [__] Tick Tock
I saw a year or something I read but I
remember the opposite Wheaties is like
eat this you'll be an athlete you'll
probably have sex yeah you'll shoot
ropes whoa yeah
[Music]
exactly dude so now that you're killing
it what like do you have like the big
thing like do you have any big specials
out yet uh so I'm filming my first
special uh July 14th and 15th in Austin
I'm filming my next special July 14th oh
[__] we're at yeah in London and England
okay I was gonna say I would if we're
both in Austin at the Paramount Theater
yeah the Paramount that's where I filmed
my first spot really it's funny oh my
God yeah that's where I'm doing my first
one I'm so excited the tickets just went
on sale this week and uh there we go how
many shows are you doing three so yeah
over two nights uh yeah one Friday two
Saturday I think most people just do two
I I was talking to somebody like get
that first one out just so you feel the
room right you know I just I I want to
overshoot it just so I have options
because I mainly just want to have one
show that I can use nine percent of I
was like that was the one isn't that Tom
Segura said he did four shows for a
special right yeah yeah I don't think
you can over shoot I know somebody who
did seven right
um at a smaller theater and you know he
just wanted that one golden show it's
not like he's cutting up seven different
shows this is kind of that one for sure
the Paramount I did that last year it's
a really good spot it felt big but not
too big where you're lost optically it
looks really well uh really good yeah
yeah when did you do yours there uh
November of 2015 15 2015 yeah that's
awesome man any notes anything and we
did it was great dude Texas has always
been I love Texas like the uh I I say
this a lot when I'm performing in Texas
that I really think there's something to
that saying Don't Mess with Texas
because yeah I find that the crowds are
just respect
good energy and they're respectful like
it's everything that you want in a crowd
they're excited man I think that's why
Austin's like a great kind of Hub you
get the mixture of like the the guys who
are driving from like Lubbock and
Sugarland and they're [__] yeed out
and they're ready to shoot Copenhagen in
their Mountain Dew then drink it you
know but but you also just get the tech
Bros and Austin who are just like work
moved here for work and it's just
Perfect Blend and it's the center I mean
in my head of the US if you kind of
think about it it's right it's right
kind of you get both sides so if you're
putting out a special go live from
Austin Austin's a big enough City where
somebody in New York oh I know Austin
I'll do it but I almost did it in uh
Phoenix which I love phenomenal shows of
Phoenix but I just didn't know if
optically and and saying it does it
sound like if somebody's like yeah live
from you know Phoenix are people gonna
be yeah you know but Austin is like a
meme in itself yeah you know look at the
Austin City Limits Yeah Austin feels to
me me a lot like Nashville and Portland
I have like that keep it weird kind of a
Vibe yeah I just thought it was a
perfect blend for somebody to be like
this makes sense of something I would
watch and a lot of people are hearing
about Austin right now from Comedy just
because Rogan and all those guys so I
thought it was a good uh it just sounds
it's an easy pitch oh I did it on oh
that's great yeah
um yeah I think any state that and this
isn't a political stance but any state
that voted for Trump has the best crowds
I don't know what it is but those red
States [__] turn up Florida because
they're like hard-working Americans so
when they go out they want to get their
money worth at a show yeah like San
Diego we all know who you voted for San
Diego but those shows are [__] a
blast out there you know not to say San
Francisco wasn't a blast so fun but I
think a lot of people keep running off
in fentanyl in Portland
yeah yeah we went to Portland like uh
when we were touring with bam oh so
gnarly dude it was like yeah because
been in Portland we've been to Portland
several times and it was so [__] bad
this time that like they were locking
the doors to the stores you couldn't
walk either people were smoking tin foil
heroin almost everywhere you live in the
open just on the sidewalk people with
the the lighters under the tin foil and
shooting up like just foil everywhere
all over the ground yeah stores closed
and like you have to knock on it I mean
dude I remember the first time I saw a
foil on the ground I was like damn
they'd be cooking a lot out here I
didn't know it was for drugs you know so
I I was like a lot of leftovers a lot of
meal prepping in Portland you know well
like we're pulling over to park to go
into a store and you get out and there's
a guy just lighting up a foil
but that's the thing that decriminalized
it yeah they can't get in trouble so
they're not nothing's wrong that's crazy
I think about the times where I grew up
in in Cameroon I got a ticket for riding
skateboard without a helmet yeah and now
those guys just smoking PCP just in
front of a safe way you know how does
that check out I don't know how do you
do with with substances you drink a lot
uh no I don't really like to drink like
I've definitely had my time at you know
went to college tried a lot of stuff in
there but I don't like feeling not like
myself and anytime I have like a bad
hangover or like a come down off if I go
to like Coachella for a weekend that
like those couple days after and I don't
feel like myself and I feel like I like
I just get so frustrated yeah yeah yeah
like serotonin I remember I've only
taken Molly once and I remember it was
coming back from Coachella and I was
like on Google like how to get my
serotonin back and it's like dark
chocolate and lavender and sure enough
that night I went to Target and I was
like do you guys have lavender and dark
chocolate like some [__] freak yeah
okay you gotta not jack off for a week
but yeah I remember getting dark
chocolate and just huffing lavender so I
don't think uh thankfully I don't have
an addictive personality I don't think
but um I you would know by now
there are a whole lot of things you
would know about yourself if you had a
whoop band the most sophisticated
Fitness tracking device known to man for
example I happen to know that I got my
day started with 96 recovery why is that
because I'm drinking enough water I'm
getting enough sleep I'm doing all the
right things and it's good to know that
and what do I do with this information I
take it to the streets I gotta get out
there I gotta ride my skateboard I gotta
ride my bike I gotta exercise so that I
can
take advantage of this opportunity now
this is just like a tiny fraction of how
much you learn about yourself if you
have whoop you're gonna know about how
oxygenated your blood is you're gonna
know about the temperature of your skin
while you're sleeping this is important
like it's gonna alert you to things that
are
dangerous or concerning that you might
not otherwise know about you're going to
know about all the stages of sleep that
you have and that's important to know
you're gonna know about all the calories
you're burning the the activities you're
doing it's uh the most important thing
if you want to be serious about your
health and your Fitness you got to get
on your whoop band and the app and if
you go to whoop.com that's
w-h-o-oop you you can get yourself
started with the whoop band 4.0 comes
with a waterproof charger that slides on
top and boom you're Off to the Races and
if you use the promo code Stevo at
checkout then you get 10 off your order
one more time it's whoop.com with the
promo code Stevo if you've been thinking
about doing it then now is the time
because man I love whoop and dude I'm
gonna get out there and kill it knowing
what recovery I have today whoop.com
folks let's get back to it yeah I think
you have friends that are also like that
as well so I think I uh it just sounds
like you do not have a dent in addictive
yeah I don't think so so with the the
special in Austin is it going to a
streamer to a like yes so it did get
picked up by a streamer super uh pumped
on that
um so it's cool can we say what
streamers uh I don't know if I've said
yet okay well then we won't yeah I don't
think I have we won't trip uh but I'm
very excited for it like it's a really
cool um opportunity and they've been uh
fans for a while and they've been kind
of following the journeys and they're uh
they're actually coming out to the show
tonight in Brea so I gotta I don't like
when people tell me that like you ever
have that I mean I mean I love it but
what love I don't love having people
whose opinions really matter at my show
you're getting your head at all not
really I just get like more uh yeah the
more people that you know that are in
the audience The More Alive you are the
more people if I was doing I'd be like
oh [__] everybody's here like you you do
that you love that [__] yeah I just I
got something there I'm getting
something to proved like I want them
like and and when there are people in
the audience who who matter to me right
like God do I have a short fuse for
[__] at the audience it does make
you really be on your your you know your
fight or flight but it's sometimes and
once you're on stage you're not thinking
about it you're locked in as long as
that first joke it's you're kind of like
you're in you're in the saddle of stand
up but it is it's like right before you
go on the hey Mike Tyson's in the front
row you're like why would you all
[__] see him you think I would miss
Mike Tyson in the front row Mike Tyson
came to see my show on time really yeah
yeah he was a pretty boys though no yeah
yeah so that's like fun because like
that's just a friend but I was at the
Hollywood improv somebody's like you're
Mike Tyson I was like yeah what am I
gonna crowd what do you do for a living
knock people out cool moving on like how
are you with hecklers at your shows do
you not put up with it or do you [__]
with them it depends if you're just
drunk and yelling at nonsense they're
not adding anything then I then it's
annoying but if somebody there's certain
parts of my set where if I say something
I might get a response or I talk about
like this graffiti I saw that said like
[__] love right and I thought that was
such a funny thing to you know in like
you know like gangster bubble thought
like [__] love and so I talk about that
and sometimes when I say [__] love
you'll get some girl like whoo and
you're like oh what's going on with you
are you what you go through a
relationship but I think if it's
somebody yells something out or I have
videos that people will call out like I
made fun of Subarus in a video and then
if I reference cars like I like have a
whole bit about guys with like kind of
like loud cars and somebody what about
Subaru truth so those are things I don't
really look for it but there is moments
where somebody could chime in so I don't
mind it
um but if they're just drunk and they're
just talking and wing dings there's not
much you can do with that right I get
that so much
it drives me yeah that's I mean
Whole Foods you know it drives me nuts
and um it like so I draw a pretty hard
line with it you know like I just take
the position that like here I've got all
these people that came out to enjoy a
show that's true that's like you're just
vandalizing the show disrespecting
everybody here and
um so like I make it very clear that
that I don't yeah it is weird when you
have to be kind of like the parent a
little bit when you're like hey like
look I know you're having a lot of fun
but there's 500 people here that I'll
pay they got babysitters this and then
the person's so drunk they don't know
what's happening right and then the
problem is that there are a couple
points in my show we're all actually ask
the question I'll ask you a crowded
question is everybody's scared to like
oh answer it
well I've done the opposite where I
asked the crowd a question I'm like yeah
what do you guys do in insert City and
then it's just like nobody and it's just
too much at once or you say the wrong
thing like you're in Philly and you know
you're like yeah what is the best place
to get a cheese stick and then it's just
a gang Turf and the ishma Bibles you
gotta get and then they're just yelling
out God Gino's gonna and you're like
guys guys guys guys guys guys right and
I don't really watch a lot of sports and
I remember in Philly I said something
about or no no uh uh Bill's Mafia
Buffalo I referenced something about
football and they have a chant and it
went on for maybe a minute but it felt
like an hour everybody in there is doing
it and I'm just standing there like it's
happy birthday singing to me and I'm
just like
cool when is this gonna end I don't know
Sports I don't know what is going on
right now but was that at uh helium it
was at some venue that used to be a
church then they turned into a theater
it was actually really neat I forget who
owned it but it was like an old rock
star turned it into a thing it was
really cool there was like stained glass
and the shows at seven so you can still
see the light the Lord beaming through a
little bit but uh yeah it shows like
that are but but then it's like what am
I gonna do disrespect this city for
being like you guys can't have pride in
your football team I like when cities do
that like uh was it like Denver or
Portland OR Oregon where they'll do
they'll convert a church into a
restaurant or they'll come yeah it's an
interesting Play Nightclub yeah it's big
in Denver really they had yeah churches
will be nightclubs it's kind of a trip
10 years ago this whole I mean even the
Denver Airport you know I just learned
about that recently yeah I've been
watching uh some WF podcasts and it went
through the yeah it's bizarre it's
bizarre but I didn't know they turn into
bars there yeah
night clubs and [__] that's interesting
the first time I got drunk was at church
that's a hilarious that'd be kind of a
cool [__] place to just you know that
would be good how did you get drunk at
church that was an altar boy this sounds
like a Theo box store right here so so
you I was like we would go in the back
and just pound it the wine or the wine
yeah I'm not getting pounded yeah
no I was like in fourth grade or third
grade by guzzling the wine and it was
like seven in the morning God damn going
back to school just [__] drunk that's
so funny you guys are over there just
like drinking you're like oh man I think
she gave me cooties you guys got the
Sorrows back there yeah it was wild I
mean a lot of [__] went down to Catholic
School oh yeah you know it's [__]
it's a [__] up place did you uh grow
up religious uh I was raised Jewish my
mom was Jewish dad was Christian and my
mom pushed it really heavy on me in the
beginning which is fine like you know
that's all she wanted to do but I it
kind of just deterred me away from it
because she pushed it so heavy can you
enchant the Torah uh
uh I I know the OG songs I know like the
bandwagon songs you know like uh
Isaac
oh yeah Isaac just started chanting him
over like what where did that come from
did you watch Ari's special I did it's
so good so so good I wow in my head I
couldn't stop thinking about the candles
and I was like that's unbelievable
that's a production set you know if
you're doing multiple shows or cut the
candles in uh but I thought that looked
great unbelievable it uh it took him 20
minutes to light all the candles did it
really yeah God it's uh I'm so impressed
with that Ari shafir Jimmy special well
yeah that was great and that was the
proof of YouTube being like look you can
drop a really good special right yeah
yeah you guys already have your sets
picked out for your specials is that a
big process or how does that work
uh like stage set your production design
oh production sorry
um I Loosely have it in my head but then
again you see a guy like Ari's and
you're like oh there is room to do
whatever the hell you want dude that I
don't know how to be as ambitious as Ari
was yeah
um my first special in Austin
um like I I call that special guilty as
charged so it was like a big like jail
bars and and this huge mug shot yeah
like thing you know there was it was
very thematic and then my my second
special I taped in Denver was just was
just not and I think this this new one
same deal like nothing behind it because
I'm uh
uh doing it in London I'm pretty
determined to uh have a like a big black
London taxi cab drive me drive onto the
stage for me to get out oh that's cool
uh yeah I think that it might be more
like a classic to have just a clean set
behind you maybe now 2015 I think that
was like a time and I also think about
like guys like Nick Swardson who I love
uh watching I I think his like early on
specials had a lot of stuff in the
background I think it's more common to
have a busy background but now it's kind
of like you know either do one thing
like all the candles and that's it all
you do like I was thinking about maybe
doing like a string of like some like
light bulbs I did like some random City
and uh Royal Oak Michigan where they had
light bulbs on the curtain and it looked
really neat especially with a depth of
field somebody just just rip Ari is a
candle thing but just with thousands of
Lights Christmas lights but this one I
mean it added some depth and it wasn't
just the background so I'm trying to
think like what's this Middle Ground of
like oh this looks good and also like
what there's too much going on back
there you know what's what's your
special gonna be called if sorry I don't
really know I'm in between a few titles
but Christian
the Christian boy
um I don't I have a few ideas in mind
but it's um I don't know I was gonna
shoot it and then kind of see what spoke
to me I think I have a few ideas but I'm
not 100 sure yet do you have your name
picked out yeah I mean it's the bucket
list tour oh great well that's the story
on right now yeah like in the beginning
um you know
never have like a name for your show
when you first start touring it's just
you're at a comedy club and it's Stevo
is here yeah yeah and then I would go on
some like International tours and they'd
be really important for for me for the
promoter that I come up with the name
for the tour yeah so like you know I had
different names and it was just kind of
all over the place but now as I put
together a show I'm very clear on what
it is yeah yeah I mean I that's the tour
that I did was called uh are you that
guy because it's like that's the most
common thing I'll get like on the street
like dude are you that guy Are You The
Tick Tock guy you do the thing or they
just think I'm the Jacksonville Jaguars
quarterback Trevor Lawrence and I'm like
close enough people call me Trevor Noah
and I'm like I'll take it
so you know that kind of played into the
theme of like people know my face but
not my name but I I only really have
like a two-minute joke on that so I
don't know if I want to wrap the whole
special around that or just take like
one really one of my favorite jokes in
it and then make that the title I I
would
um encourage you not to have the title
of the special be about people not
knowing your name no exactly exactly I'm
just gonna call it who the [__] is this
guy
should I skip this yes yeah
yeah I think we're going I'm going
simple I'm also thinking about what's
going to roll off the tongue you go have
you seen blah blah blah have you seen it
right have you seen Bucket List have you
seen you know I don't want the whole
have you seen are you that guy that just
sounds like like a murder show on Hulu
or something yeah have you seen or I've
never thought about that have you seen
are you there now I'm like why'd I call
it the bucket list you know that I've
seen bucket list because you got to
think about what's the abbreviate
because I always think about that for
like rappers or like DJs you want a
quick you know this one have you heard
of this guy or if you like you follow
somebody on Instagram like what is it
they're like it's Trevor with four e's
two r's and you're like this is two yeah
this is too many you gotta just and then
there's Andrew Santino like uh do you
think cheeseburger yeah cheeseburger
yeah that was that was good yeah I
enjoyed that yeah I thought that the
stage set the production design for
cheeseburger was like it's clearly Bland
now let me tell you about something that
is not Bland whatsoever which I travel
with everywhere I go it is ag1 from
athletic greens and little secret about
this I've been using less and less water
when I drink it in the mornings because
it's just that delicious and that's how
I do it okay why do I do it because it
gives me all the nutrition I need I
could hypothetically have a bad diet and
not worry about it because I got all the
nutrition I need in my comprehensive
convenient ag1 travel pack now of course
it's a good idea to eat healthy as well
and I do that sometimes better than
others but I always have my ag1 so that
I know I'm covered and you should jump
on this deal that I have for you to get
five of these travel packs completely
for free at athletic greens.com
Stevo and with your first order five of
these travel packs plus an entire year's
supply of immune boosting vitamin D yes
that's right I use this every day I
bring it everywhere I go and you're
gonna know why if you go to
athleticgreens.com Stevo right now now
let's get back to it yeah I mean he but
he strikes me as a guy that somebody
came to him was like do you want to do
his background do you want to do all
this [__] he's like that's stupid you're
like you're right it sure is we'll do a
lounge leather chair it's the same
director that did cheeseburger and Jew
oh really nice cheeseburger too the same
production company I know I I met with
him I think we're gonna I think he's
gonna do Eric Abrams uh uh the same
production company uh 800 pound gorilla
yeah yeah yeah yeah so
um they're on board to do mine but but
it is and that's the thing with the you
know the set design you do a chair and
somebody goes I wish you did more and
then somebody goes no it's it's stand up
just enjoy the jokes you know yeah I'm
also worried about the the audience who
my audience is very like you know
probably like 18 to like 28 and I'm like
the stimulation I feel like every 10
minutes I gotta just look directly in
the camera but get off your phone you
know like I gotta like through the
special right or you gotta just put
giant subtitles that pop up on it you
know every two seconds yeah you're gonna
have the Yonder bags
uh probably I'm also the people at home
you know because it's like the audience
to watch an hour like I don't know the
last time I went an hour without
checking my phone it's so I'm just
thinking about the people at home I'm
just gonna randomly have a pair of tits
that pop up just very special
I think that people are pretty good
about once they're locked into a show I
would agree on TV I would agree but I'm
just saying my own like habits where
I'll be like watching like Dave spell
arguably the greatest comedian and I'm
like
it's just your body's like uh muscle
memory so I'm just like how can I make
sure that I'm interesting the set's
interesting uh the set that I'm doing is
interesting you know I just really want
to appeal to the audience and you know
it's just funny because in the comedy
club it just so locked into your present
but then somebody at home you know it's
just got to be just gotta be good and
that's that's what I'm working on now is
tighten it up yeah you started doing
comedy what year I was
2011. 2011 and so it took some time off
in college but really like predominantly
getting after it in 2014 is when I like
really I was going to open my except for
class and so like nine years you've been
doing comedy and you're doing your first
special is that like the average
lifespan of somebody in comedy starting
from the ground zero he gets a special
it's more about less I mean I think
that's not that right yeah I think about
eight years is when people kind of do
most people I know did like one after
around eight years but now it's like
that was the people that I knew they're
doing after eight years before for like
Comedy Central and all these other
streamers but they're like half hour
specials right like a solid hour it was
like that or or whatever I don't think
there is like uh but I would say that's
average but now with YouTube people put
them out after two years people put them
out after 10 years you know it's not
really I uh
I'm grateful that
I have my first special to Mark how much
progress I've made right I mean it's
with anything I look at the videos I was
making you know four years ago what the
[__] is this you know so imagine 10
years right
but and that's almost all I can say that
I'm proud of for my first special is
just the progress I've made since then
like I did it too soon really how many
years in were you
um I was five five years okay and when
was
um gnarly how many years gnarly was uh
eight a little over two years after that
after it was not enough time to get
another hour together it
I think it was I think it was and um
then now since then it's been five years
oh yeah there you go and uh and dude
this my my new hours
like like gradually over the course of
the time of me doing stand-up it it
became multimedia you know at first it
was just me and Mike then it was me and
a Mike and I edited footage in after the
facts to illustrate the stories and then
the third hour now like footage comes on
the road it's multimedia in the theater
oh and that's a great way just to really
fully get a full show people leave there
they can picture oh dude it's gonna be a
full speed it's like it's like each item
on my bucket list gets like a crazy
story and then pay off the story with
the footage right but I mean you
wouldn't have thought of that for your
first special like that's a truly
veteran Stevo right there really mapping
it out yeah what was that aha moment it
was just after taping the first special
while putting together the second hour
and I was performing on stage in a
comedy club in Atlanta I remember and I
thought oh my God like these these
stories that I'm putting together this
new hour with live like almost all of it
happened on camera in some fashion so I
could I could edit the footage in after
the fact and have it be a multimedia
experience my head exploded also
escaping the stuff you do is so extreme
that the list somebody in the crowd is
trying to picture it and it's a thousand
times gnarlier than what it is so once I
see it on the camera they're like oh
[__] this is not only one real but two
now they're experiencing it so when you
talk about it they're right there with
you it's so much fun for me because it
like largely stand-up comedy is just
licensed to make up complete [__]
stories exactly yeah if it's not
completely made up it's just so like you
know more blown and exaggerated whereas
like my material is just like 100 yeah
truthful exactly and so like having the
receipts to provide is just it uh it's
really fun I think if somebody wasn't
full like it's something your average
story that you're telling or video
sounds almost made up like I was doing
whippets in Denmark with four strippers
and then somebody's like yeah I don't
believe it then you're like bloop and
they're like oh [__] yeah that was a
giraffe it's a hundred percent how my
show plays out and I'm loving it
you haven't thought about doing
multimedia stand up I I have uh I did a
show one time in Hollywood and it was I
forget what it's called but essentially
you had a clicker and you would go to
and it was to essentially animate your
set and I had so much fun doing it
because with the right timing you you
know it can be the punch lineup with
your punch line so it hits double heart
top yeah yeah yeah so 18 caratop I
haven't heard he's amazing day is so fun
pretty unreal he's great but um I think
that would be the next level of this
because there's no right or wrong of
like how it has to be done and the way
to uh you know kind of evolve with the
decreasing attention span right yeah of
people in smartphone
civilization right exactly I think it's
to feed them like yeah yeah that's a
good point actually when you're in brand
tonight that's a huge LEDs
they're all set up four and it's way
better than the LED brick screen they
put behind you you're like yeah who's
buying that this is brick brick and
mortar back here yeah it's the best look
at that that
Brandy yeah say hi to Brittany for us is
she work there yeah oh no I know the
club manager yeah I didn't didn't like
she like kicked someone's ass they're
acting up in the audience four times a
night like she [__] people up The
Comedy Club like managers and owners are
low-key like mob people like they'll
come in the green room with like a blood
eye like yeah I just got swung at uh did
you need anything you want any food to
go well the crazy thing is like she's
hot in like and she [__] people up and
we talked about it when we had Mark
Norman on the podcast but like uh yeah
that that's what throws you off because
she's the sweetest girl the nicest girl
and then also I'm gonna try to get
backstage baby you walk in and she's
like has her [__] forearm up your
throat and it's like get this guy out of
here
yeah I'll check to see if she's got any
blood on her Knuckles when I see her
tonight she probably does yeah but yeah
that's a it is funny how they'll look so
I forget where I was at but some club
owner got pushed by somebody into it
like where a curb was behind them you
know they almost got like tabletop by
the curb and he just came in he's like
kind of sweating he's like yeah
pushed down but um you guys good you
need anything you still need a ride home
you need a ride to the hospital yeah you
know Life Alert what's happening it was
at the Brea Improv where I recorded
um this YouTube video uh it was it was
an old bit that I didn't put in my
special called celebrities I did cocaine
I've seen this yeah that thing that uh a
lot of a lot of views yeah like like 10
million God damn I mean but that's
something you have to get on video
because people are just like
I don't believe it and then you're going
through the stories and the details that
one I didn't have for that that's like a
big reason why it wasn't in that
multimedia special because there is no
footage of Paris Hilton rack in the line
yeah nobody likes cameras out when
you're racking lines of course yeah like
you a narc what's going on here oh it's
for my special yeah yeah that's so funny
man
um but yeah I remember too because it
like it's a huge room 550 seats that's
crazy for a comedy club the ceilings are
super low I love it wearing their
[__] flying drones oh really holy
[__] that's next level she's not being
hammered like that's how you lose
somebody's return to their Hammer like
the [__] government
yeah
that's rad man congrats um super super
stoked for you but uh like do you have
any any other like big projects in the
works with the sketch stuff it seems
like uh this was kind of like so we
pitched a show during the pandemic and
we kind of pitched a few things and it's
kind of like you know it's very like
yeah this is a thing you know there's
not like any like sudden ax on it so I
was like you know let's do the special
really focus on that and then afterwards
um use that momentum hopefully to you
know go out to the market be like hey we
also want to do this or whatever it is
but mainly just that I think I think
about like very three months at a time
and I'm like this yeah I want to focus
on the special
I got Vinnie over here is uh getting
into sketch comedy nice how's it going
yeah it's been fun it is I got something
going that I'm really stoked on a pitch
in the show or you're just I'm working
on a project right now not for any not
French particular uh thing but she's got
like Banger sketches yeah that he is
holding out hope that there's a home for
other than YouTube he's hoping that
there's a project that he can sell yeah
yeah I mean that's the weird part about
YouTube is it's almost like it's like
proof of concept where you post it on
there it does well uh and then it's like
a trademark yeah well then Network execs
go like there is an audience for this
for sure well my idea behind the whole
thing was like start this catch this
sketch group yeah the whole social media
Thing YouTube Every platform and then
have something like the consistency with
that going and then at the same time
work on this quote unquote pilot and
have everything ready yeah Bible yeah of
course yeah yeah I I think it's just
people I mean Network exact only care
about numbers same thing about common
clubs they care about numbers so it's
like they're like yeah this is funny but
once you put like a million views
underneath it optically they're like
whoa audience money cash you know
they're just they're just AI robots up
at Fox being like
buy it right and and so he just filmed a
Vinnie filmed a sketch and um like a a
jail cell and like a courtroom yeah it's
like man how much it cost you to rent
those sets yeah a few grand like it's
like 2 500 right but now you're all
stressed out about dude like uh you know
I got like
to cost so much to make my sketches
isn't that counterintuitive in today's
world well yeah I I yeah I can write it
off my head but at first you're like oh
[__] that's a lot but then you go like
all right you got to spend money to make
money all right is it better to shoot
this in a a real jail cell where it
looks good or you green screen a jail
cell and suddenly your hair is like
caught in the green screens and all that
you could I would encourage you with
where you're at and went through because
that's the thing is that Vinnie's not
been able to build a YouTube audience
because historically he's done like the
gnarliest most violent like jackass
stuff like dropping darts off bridges
into his body like you know like and so
like he's just prison pocket [__] he's
just strike after strike
so like now he's doing like genuinely
funny sketch comedy like instead of this
just but I but I kind of want to like
integrate this the stunts and sketches
and kind of mesh it into one it's kind
of like a Mr show yeah just sit there
when you put your episodes on YouTube
that they can get demonetized
it's a good hook you know can you can
you air those on Rumble and not get a
strike I don't know
I don't know much about it yeah I don't
know much about it either
I've been introduced to the CEO of
Rumble but I gotta imagine what it looks
like and he is get to respond to me oh
really I like I'm like kind of like yeah
like the the people who introduced me to
him they'll like Loop me in on one guy
Loop me in on an email another guy
looped me in on a text yeah and uh that
you know I hear from the people like oh
the the CEO of Rumble says if you want
to say it to me and I'm thinking like oh
I guess he doesn't really want me on the
platform yeah but you started a page
though right I mean yeah but like my
next question was gonna be are you gonna
put the prison pocket on Rumble I I mean
yeah that's a place
I'm a sensitive guy I need to be
acknowledged for sure you know now I'm
just like kind of resistant to do
anything with Rumble yeah yeah all he
needs to do is like thumbs up one text
and you're like
I'll do it he's in it right and it's so
crazy because kids just like off the
nose
cut off my nose despite my face damn you
know like uh it was a silent scorn yeah
man I just don't get it I don't get it
I'd imagine the CEO of rumbles probably
in the Barbados doing Academy and for
most of these days
the text messages he just can't move his
arm to like right exactly he's like
Stevo and then his arms are just Frozen
yeah dude I mean he why there's a
hundred percent chance he wants you on
the app he's just probably just doing
something wrong I mean I feel like
January 6 you know I have I have such a
wealth of content that is oh my God
YouTube yeah you've been filming your
whole life for I mean your whole life
right so you get so much content I if if
I were inclines to like really you know
make a thing out of it and promote it I
imagine I would bring a lot of people
there but I can't bring myself to do
that because I've not been acknowledged
you made your own Rumble app despite
Rumble
yeah you have to show your [__] to
log on like face ID
yeah I think there's something there I
mean that's a whole fingerprint yeah I
mean that type of level of petty is like
how like there's a nightclub in Vegas I
forget which one it was but they opened
because a guy didn't get let in guy
didn't get let in so he makes his own
nightclub and now it's like caucus
honestly yeah it's like latte hilarious
yeah it's a spite store exactly dude so
imagine that you just slam dunk on
Rumble right but in the middle of
developing the app he's like yes Eva
we'd love to have you all right yeah I
don't need this anymore fire the
engineers yeah
mean you just become a tech billionaire
because it just blows up I'm the same
way you know pass me on to an to an
underlying like hey dude like just kind
of just gonna Loop you in with somebody
who can really like give you some
attention and help dude I feel like I
applied to be on Raya the dating app 12
months ago nothing and all my friends
like every time I tell someone I'm not
on they're like dude you're not on there
my friend who's a PA on a Disney Plus
show is on there you have to tell them
you got denied I don't need I don't even
I don't think right what's that it just
says like waiting app and I'm just like
what but now once I get if I ever get
approved I'm gonna be like I don't want
to be on here anyways it's that same
like rejection like just let me know
like hey you're next in line maybe just
something right I said it just says like
you're waiting you have to be invited to
go on that right exactly yeah but like
I'm sure he has eight well for sure yeah
yeah yeah I had a girl I was on a date
with be like oh I can get you an
invitation I was like I don't think you
know how dates work
but yeah now it's like their rejection
to me I'm like I don't even want to be
on your stupid app
so funny man that's what podcasts are
for us to air your grievance
and Ryan are going to listen to this
podcast like well you can stay where
you're at it's just passive aggressively
it's funny you can write it off I
remember like 20 21 or 2020. I wasn't
verified on Instagram and I got to the
point where I applied for it a few times
I was like man [__] this just doesn't
even matter I know my own value I know
my own worth and then literally like the
next morning wake up blue check mark and
I was like oh dude I'll [__] I'm
better than everybody how was that
Pechanga doing shows and I like saw I
went into the lobby I was like bring me
the buffet [__] I'm verified like if
the the status it did to my head was
crazy and it just got verified like a
month and a half ago did you buy it or
did you know the day no it was like a
week before that oh really I've been
applying every 30 to every 30 days for
[__] two years it was pretty close to
the day they like yeah that's annoying
because then you have to be like it's
real yeah I promise I I think it had
something to do with wild ride because I
was putting in Wild red links in the
application yeah yeah and I have a few
pieces of press like I mean times you
just submit to Instagram to be verified
every 30 days for two years damn oh wow
so 24 I believe
dude like right here Trevor's proof that
you can you can do everything that you
want to do oh for sure we got him on the
Wild Ride podcast it's a good platform
for him of course we've been like uh
we're trying to get him to 30 000
followers yeah on uh what oh hey
um we uh announced that when I said I
was gonna do it in the intro of another
podcast and now it's the winner we we
gave away
um do we want to say the winner on here
we might as well yeah Vinnie's blue
check mark who gets it one of the
cameras died one of the cameras died
really uh I think that one I heard it I
heard a noise yeah sorry I have the same
camera at our podcast studio so the
second you hear that you're like oh [__]
no dude I mean you're on the the fish
eye dog we can just punch in on you on
the fish I thought it's on
I mean I don't care but
um so but on the Steve Aoki podcast we
said uh we were talking about
accumulation of frequent flyer miles
yeah and I've got all these frequent
flyer miles and I want to hook somebody
up and and give them uh a free vacation
uh that's great so we invited people to
follow Vinnie and Pitch to to Vinnie oh
smart and there was this uh this lady
who's a mother with an autistic child
her name is Ashley her name is Ashton
her Instagram is Ash EJ and does she win
yeah yeah who has an Elsa yet
those anti-climatic announcement her
name is Ashley
you're going to Cabo on Tuesday
going to New York City with her mom who
just had a cancer scare oh she decided
New York City she is not Vegas
but I would feel safer about that like
if my person like one to go to bed I
guess I'd be like okay well like like
we're paying for the flights but nothing
on the on the room we're not paying for
any of your once you're there because
that could be a slippery slope you know
I put 50 Grand on red you know but New
York's great yeah we go to the flights
and then I'll book her the hotels this
week yeah we're gonna pay for everything
what was her pitch or was she just kind
of like letting you know like she just
hasn't had a break yeah
she wanted to spend time with her mom
her mom was like a cancer survivor I
think yeah oh good for you guys did you
have any pitches in your DMs that were
just like hilarious like I need to get
away from my ex-wife yeah for sure I
mean it wasn't even that funny one of
them was just like Oh I wanna eat beaver
in a cool place and that was it you know
you should do it he actually did bring
that one to my attention
there's a guy who wants to eat beaver
and I was like that's and you know me
about eating Beaver yeah is what you do
it's like you pay for your flight but
we'll bump you to business class
17 yeah
because I would do that right and I'll
tell everybody in my room like Stevo
bought this how um are you doing with
frequent flyers I got a lot which is
great it's awesome Platinum yeah I feel
Unstoppable like when the flight attends
to scan mine because I look like a young
kid so if I'm sitting up you know there
and they're like all right now boarding
Platinum members or whatever when I walk
up to like this [__] nepo baby who
gives a [__] you got a rich dad then
they see how many miles I have like good
sir you know like there's hand me the
keys to fly the damn thing so yeah it's
funny when I go backpacking I'll get
bumped up to first class and then I
backpack for like a month or two yeah
and I look worse than this and I'm
wearing a backpack and for and people
are just like who the [__] is this well
I remember I was flying to a bachelor
party with all my friends to Austin
actually we're all leaving out of LAX
and I I was like let's get a road
together you know just in the back we're
like row like 22 and right as I Scan
they go up Miss Wallace you've been
bumped to first class and I was like
but then I'd walk back to my free out
club like how are you [__] Polaris
doing back here
um you said Platinum we're talking about
are you loyal to American Airlines uh
Delta I like Delta yeah whoever smelt it
Delta yeah there you go American
Airlines it doesn't do anything for me
it's just fine okay you gotta put your
own damn phone up there
okay what do you mean like like they
don't have TVs on any of the the
headrests Oh you mean I was like your
candy they make you scan your own phone
headrest is like you clip your phone you
have a executive platinum on American
and so you just fly that much I yeah I
fly a lot so you're you're in all of the
frequent player programs Delta's the
highest I think I have like some status
on American it's like not the number one
but it's probably like the second or
third the one you can get but yeah I
mean I just did a whole US tour uh last
year and then half the year before that
so I mean it was like 48 cities and
that's a lot of I'm gonna go ahead and
say that American does it for me really
good yeah
an announcement from America then you
did the winner yeah
American Airlines is is uh they scratch
my Edge what about it they uh I I I love
them how many miles do you have I am a
million Miler how many over a million
though like are you like one one oh I
don't know so what is it that uh is it
their customer service or is it the best
customer service in the game yeah I'm
trying to think because most flights for
the most part unless you're in like
those like Jet Blue like pods we lay
down which I've done one mint yeah I
heard that everybody likes mint oh well
it's [__] up because not us we like
American
right is this brand new for America but
mint was like you know I've never done
Molly and had sex but that's what
everyone says they're like don't ever
have sex it's too good to return I have
an American
promo code wild ride but it felt like it
was actually British Airways which is
One World Alliance yeah
I bought the British Airways flights on
American but I felt like once I flew men
I was like oh no this is too nice yeah
you want me to go back to sitting up
horizontal and not vertical wait flipped
there we go one of the two but you're
laying down there's like a little door
that you can close it for sure I think
of your little chocolates I'm like oh
how'd you know my serotonin was low they
got the little eye patches it's a whole
thing and then you're just back to see
on American I'm looking at flights for
Steve when he flies somewhere like yeah
lay down like I'm scouring like lay down
is the only way to go if you're not
doing private yeah I've never done that
by the way it's private fun we just got
back from Australia and we did private
quite a bit I mean that's what fifty
thousand dollar flight it was so sick we
spent about 60 000. Australian dollars
on four different in Australia not two
Australia
okay I was gonna say two Australia yeah
no no
within Australia we were bouncing around
on private jets and they have a lot more
turbulence no because they're smaller I
didn't notice that dude and I'm so
excited
damn yeah there's such a rich altitude
they're just like it was just like on
takeoff you're just like
and you're already in the air wow yeah
dude so we so we got a uh we gotta pack
this this uh Paramount Theater in Austin
dude it's gonna be great uh the so
there's three shows the third show just
went up today the first two are first
one sold out second one is very close
are you uh the third show is on the film
so Friday we just announced we did
Saturday yeah Saturday was uh the 15th
we did the seven o'clock first that sold
out in a day which was awesome then we
just added the second for the Saturday
and now I was like all right let's do
Friday
um so it's like reverse engineering but
but yeah where do they go to get tickets
trevorwallscomedy.com and we love
American Airlines
there's no promo code but if you want
you can't type in American Airlines
after you buy it just to really uh feel
like you got a deal on it
trevorwalliscomedy.com
and that's is your main thing is just
pushing the stand up pushing the stand
up and then also put out sketches weekly
on my YouTube uh you know work really
hard on that with the uh Wallace yeah
just Trevor Wallace on pretty much
everything Tick Tock Instagram YouTube
um and really just trying to figure out
what's the next layer of YouTube I mean
you've been on the internet for so long
too you're it's like you always gotta
adapt and what's you know what's uh
what's hitting now what's hitting in the
future what what used to hit that we can
try again you know so I'm always posting
on there uh what should we talk up to
now 9.4 million which is awesome yeah
it's great man it's it's it's truly
awesome but 9.4 million I'm in a little
B for them now I saw that you're coming
up to uh close to a billion views on
YouTube uh I just hit a billion dollars
which is crazy I don't even know so sick
there's seven billion in the world and
I'm like one in seven that's [__]
nuts so
um yeah I'm gonna beef with you uh Tick
Tock because like for whatever reason
the past like month or two it's been
like kind of slow and I'm like all right
trying to take the app I don't give a
[__] anymore
I mean
it pops if it doesn't it's like right
but isn't that funny like I'll get
comments like Trevor never misses and
I'm like oh I miss I miss and I delete
them so yeah
you can maybe re-cut it or something
Paul had uh the idea he said that in in
my old drugs video the the hose where I
say like this acid is like that was cool
yeah I didn't see that was that the one
yeah my brain is so disconnected I saw
it yesterday I was watching I was like
whoa and then I was like now I'm here
well Instagram that did very well did
all right not very well but pretty good
yeah what are you happy with like on a
if if uh over Mill if uh in engagement
like less than 100 000 likes on an
Instagram post is an embarrassing
failure damn I used to remember getting
excited on Instagram when you got 11
likes it went from names to numbers do
you remember this the first 10 likes on
Instagram used to just be names and then
number 11 it would turn into the number
that was big you get that like three or
four minutes back in the day in college
sweeping up dude you're speaking about
what's the next thing on YouTube and I I
was just looking on my page yesterday
did you see the Dude Perfect video where
they went to space they had like 28
million views I I couldn't believe that
what do they do [__] shot their buddy
up in the space with like five other
people and they went to the they got
dark the gravity took over right they
did like the whole Jeff Bezos thing dude
check it out it it I was like whoa these
guys are doing this these guys kill it
they're killing it had like 28 million
views in maybe six months wow was uh and
he was like you know the [__] Earth
is around like he saw the curvature of
the earth fish I launched it
they had gravity actually they had to
unbuckle they're floating around in
gravity like legit he was throwing ping
pong balls and I was like okay that you
know debunks them saying that they're
like stringed up and doing some
acrobatics yeah unless the fish you know
fishing string the ping pong ball they
filled the ping pong balls with with uh
helium yeah
that's what's so hard about sketch
comedy how the [__] am I supposed to
compete with people sending themselves
to space yeah right and the answer is a
good thumbnail with tits in it I'll tell
you that much I mean that'll get the
clicks but yeah dude that's wild
Vinnie's Vinnie's logo has tits on it
does it yeah yeah we just got it and we
just got Vinnie a logo yeah got my girls
titties on it hell yeah yeah she's got
nice titties no offense no she's got
amazing titties yeah none taken I didn't
concur yeah I've never seen him but you
know I feel the aura going on right now
and I think they're great too
who's your favorite porn star to have on
uh Angela White probably if you've uh
heard the name she's a gray light she's
just so she's Australian Australian just
very bubbly personality just great and
honestly like just just a great
businesswoman just how she talks is so
like media trained it's so crazy and
just so profound and what she talks
about so passionate about it too you
know it wasn't like like it almost made
me sign up for porn and then I opened my
pants and I was like we're good but if
you feel the genuine like she wants to
do it she loves her job yeah she was
great on that yeah if Angela if Angela
White if you're listening you can DM me
it's traveling Siegel with one L and we
can get you on no worries yeah and he's
got a lot of miles to fly yeah so points
like you wouldn't believe I just got
back from Australia oh and flew in your
culture yeah the motherland dude yeah
damn I'm the one I can't believe I just
set you up with Angela White that's so
cool what if I got married to her it's
all because of you I'll take 10
royalties
yeah I did well right on bro I
appreciate you dude dude thanks for
having me man and uh you did our podcast
maybe like a year or two ago that was
awesome yeah how's Andy working out
Andy's great dude he's uh he's coming to
the show tonight he's giving my best
I'll shoot him a text yeah dude I'll
definitely oh my God he's reached out
so many times I've just never been able
to do different stuff yeah you know
you're a busy man yeah so uh but he's
great he's just my soundboard he's my
manager I've been with him for like six
years and you used to work with him too
I was he was Andy yeah yeah cool dude
he's just my sounding board I'll just
text him like three in the morning like
Austin Texas get me on this show I'm
like I want to host fuckboy Island I
just like send them all up and he
responds no he's not because he's at 3am
I'm up there just crackhead hours be
like I want a new I want to show on Hulu
yeah
we love him he's a great guy yeah he's
great man yeah and always wears a
tracksuit which makes me feel very good
about my money so
on that note dude thanks for having me
this is a super sick man I mean yeah
Legend So this is awesome man thanks for
the butt wipes
right you mind if I get a photo in front
of them
hey guys ah man
um that Trevor Wallace was great we love
him you know what to do
um
dude my people
um if you've seen my bucket list show
you know about Olive
passed away a week ago and today Bernie
passed away they both made it to 14
years old
but man Bernie while Paul was working
would always be Manning the fort down
here
ah it's it's sad man I cried my ass off
today uh saying goodbye to Bernie he had
lymphoma Olive uh both dogs were in in
rough shape man and so
yeah I was thinking like am I gonna post
about it like I just don't have it in me
I'm just gonna tell you guys that's it
um The Bucket List special will be
um devoted to Olive
man all right guys I love you